Hey guys, I'm Demi Lovato.
I'm on tour here in Denver and this is Undercover Lyft.
Nice to meet you, I'm Samantha.
Hi Samantha.
You can call me Sam.
I love Lyft.
I just started.
Oh, that's awesome.
Yeah, its like a job that's cool for the summer.
Do you do anything else besides Lyft?
I actually really wanna be a singer someday.
I have actually been travelling the country with my ex-boyfriend's brother...
...'cause he sings too and so, we really want to kinda get our names out there.
Open mic nights and like, whatever we can do.
What type of music do you listen to?
Have you ever met her?
God, no.
No?
That would be amazing.
That would be amazing?
Are you kidding me?
Oh okay cool, 'cause are you sure you've never met her before?
I just insulted the hell out of you.
I'm so sorry.
It's okay.
Oh my god, I love you.
Oh my God.
I totally got you to sing Camp Rock songs, everyone's gonna hear.